c'est le premier jour de la 82e saison
des sucres à la cabane Constantin située
à Saint-Eustache on y vient d'un peu
partout pour savourer les repas
traditionnels dont le fameux jambon
toupie on a toujours
mis de jambon sur les omelettes alors ça
c'est toujours été
une tradition c'est quoi sa
particularité à ce jambon là on leur a
fait cuire on le fait fumer alors c'est
deux jambons qui est vraiment à peindre
un peu alors il est bien cuit c'est ça
qui est un petit peu
c'est tellement désagréable jambon qui
est dur à manger
tout le monde a sa place dans
l'entreprise familiale André le maître
des omelettes et des assiettes
généreuses et Michel qui veille entre
autres à la cuisson parfaite du jambon
ici je vois qu'un filet à quelle étape
vous l'enlevez on l'enlève au moment
qu'on le met dans le four à vapeur on
m'a dit que c'était une invention
québécoise ce filet là c'est vrai c'est
mon père qui l'idée de demander à son
fournisseur de jambon
autrefois il y a les jambons y étaient
plus rond c'était deux cuisses qui
collent ensemble qui était attachés
aussi avec une filet mais un moment
donné pour faire des tranches ça allait
pas bien là en faisant plus un genre de
toupie qui l'ont appelé toupie et c'est
plus facile de faire des belles tranches
coupées en deux
chez les Constantin le jambon toupie
occupe une place de choix on a même pas
mis le pied à l'intérieur que les
effluves du jambon fumé nous accueillent
déjà
[Musique]
le jambon toupie c'est du porc désossé
dans les morceaux sont mélangés dans une
saumure ils sont ensuite moulés dans un
filet surnommé ce qui nette ce qui lui
confère sa forme cylindrique beaucoup
plus facile à manier
l'autre touche après la cuisson au four
à vapeur on fume les jambons de 30 à 40
minutes
sont égales c'est plus facile à
travailler aussi
[Musique]
c'est dans les années 60 que Fernand
Constantin demande conseil à son ami au
Villa Fortier pour faciliter la coupe du
jambon cette vieille bobine de film
retrouvée dans une boîte à souvenir à
rappeler une page d'histoire à toute la
famille tout le même nombre d'invités
[Musique]
dans une cabane à sucre où l'on pouvait
servir plusieurs centaines de repas par
jour il fallait dresser les assiettes
rapidement
à l'infortis on me dit que vous êtes le
petit-fils de l'inventeur du jambon
toupie est-ce que c'est vrai ah oui et
puis je peux même vous dire que l'idée
viendrait de Monsieur Constantin parce
que mon grand-père il fournissait le
jambon à l'époque et puis on est
Monsieur Constantin il y avait dit bah
c'est pas facile blablabla et mon
grand-père recommencé des tests donc il
était bouchés
le jambon et puis on met ça dans un
filet une cité Kinect
donc c'est comme le filet qui retient la
viande exactement parce qu'il fallait
trouver une manière de mettre la
pression ce jambon pour lui donner
justement sa forme arrondie
c'est bon mais c'est pas travaillerable
mais bon effectivement durant l'heure du
service ben c'est pas le temps de
commencer à faire du réseau au sol si on
veut pas des eaux simples puis mettre ça
va sécher exactement alors donc le
problème en fait que
les deux vieux les deux personnes là ils
ont travaillé des projets puis ils ont
bien réussi parce
que toutes les jambes se ressemblent
toutes les stars c'est tout le même
procédé
depuis les années 60 le jambon toupie a
traversé les modes culinaires et on le
trouve à peu près partout encore
aujourd'hui l'histoire des sucres
c'était le bout de la terre le comme
aujourd'hui il fait beau là maintenant
les matins des cousins les cousines ça
me touche
voilà parce que il y en avait toujours
un enfermé qui avait une vie alors là
tout le monde sera pourri là deux trois
fin de semaine à l'année puis remercier
ces gens-là mais que si c'était facile à
emmener c'était un jambon des œufs du
lait des patates c'est toutes des
affaires qu'on avait là sur la ferme
alors là ben pour remercier ces gens-là
qui venaient nous aider mais là il
faisait un gros non
ça me rend nostalgique ça me rappelle
l'enfance ça me rappelle les cabanes à
sucre d'antan
et Margot comment mais vous a travaillé
dans une cave ane à sucre j'aime bien
les troisièmes et 4e génération de
Constantin maintiennent les traditions
en restant fidèle au travail de leur
grand-parents Fernand et Jeannette qui
s'était éteinte à 100 ans en février
dernier on ressent encore leur présence
aujourd'hui dans l'érablière qu'ils ont
fondé en 1941